cartina dumbhead so is a winter sports
resort located 1,200 meters up in the
Dolomites it's best known for hosting
ski tournaments but this mountain resort
is also home to some culinary
specialties Tom Hill Papa names
restaurant alchemy is best known for its
local delicacies he loves the
traditional cuisine of his hometown
for example Casso Dean dumplings stuffed
with beets another typical dish is pork
medallions served with mushrooms
the Dolomites cuisine is modest and
simple but it gets its twist from rare
locally grown ingredients and special
seasonings an essential part of every
Italian dish is bread here to Cortina
d'Ampezzo has its own tradition abbiamo
quibble here we have really typical
products from Cortina d'Ampezzo here is
called Buju
a type of rye love and this is also
called bucho the difference is that this
one is fresh and the other one has been
dried they said funny Seco puja has been
produced in the local bakery for three
generations
Fabio pomp Amin is a regular customer
here the brand gets its special flavor
from the seasoning caraway mixed with a
type of wild fennel seed found only in
the Dolomites a lymphadenopathy comment
is on the inside you can see the caraway
and fennel seeds they give the bread its
unique flavor that's why I use this
bread for my dishes too just symbolizes
our tradition and our culture and all
that will do right typically Cortina
back in the kitchen Fabio Papa Neen
prepares his crusted venison to be
served with potato rosti and beet puree
his ingredients are venison with
blueberries bran wheat and Parmesan for
the bread crumbs then beets potatoes
bacon and onions for the side dishes
first put the potatoes and beets into a
pot and salted water then bring to a
boil to soften
then puree the vegetables
and some butter to get a creamy texture
not a problem a necklace it became
really compliments the venison because
it has such a sweet taste the sweetness
contrasts or the venison the strong
aroma add the salt and pepper to the
grated potato for the rusty add onions
and bacon then olive oil to taste then
pack the mixture into small shapes
rust-eze are a typical Mountain dish a
laurel a TTL efficiently roast these are
made of just potato and onion bacon
provides more flavor like it's a really
simple dish don't come for Cola great
the puja very finely to make breadcrumbs
mix the wheat mint parsley garlic
parmesan and flour together in a bowl
then drizzle with olive oil next remove
the fat from the venison loin then
season with salt and chili fry each
filet with a few blueberries and the
leaves the head chef has a tip for how
to cook them for just the right amount
of time you should touch the meat while
frying if it's firmer in the outside but
still soft in the middle then it's
perfect we then made bility add red wine
then allow the sauce to reduce remove
the meat from the pan and cut into
slices coat with mustard and then add
the breadcrumb mixture
well that's aa clavinet mal de vivre is
ready for the oven cook it for 10
minutes at 220 degrees the community
meanwhile serve the beet puree
preferably with an icing bag then add
the rusty take the venison out of the
oven and add the sauce to the plate
and it's finished
Fabio Papa need recommends a drawn
Italian red wine to accompany this
venison dish and then maybe a stroll in
the mountains to walk it off